I think what I talk about today will
build on hopefully we'll build on stuff
that we've talked about in the past for
students who are here and also for my
students hopefully it'll build on stuff
we've talked about in the past for
students are in the room I'll do a
little bit of a review but really my
goal is to talk a little bit about some
efforts that I'm involved with in terms
of trying to encourage innovation in a
developing country like Thailand in a
region like Southeast Asia so we've got
our chunk here from Thailand I'm curious
about other people are there any other
people from Asia here from Turkey okay
great India Japan and the other
countries China Hong Kong okay great
nobody from Southeast Asia outside of
our gang come on the back thank you one
I know you great okay so from Thailand
and then the rest I guess are based in
or near palo alto or somewhere in the
region so so let me let me jump into
this a little bit and really what I want
to start with is is a perspective which
is my perspective of you guys who are
based here maybe it's also your
perspective you guys based here but this
is kind of how I see entrepreneurship
over i've been working in
entrepreneurship development now for
about 15 years so as Richard said I've
been in Thailand since 1992 most of my
work is in the physical world I'm a
mechanical engineer in 1992 the problems
were not internet type problems they
were manufacturing problems that's how I
got the timeline originally and got
involved with a number of companies that
I've started and then that led me to
wanting to go back to a university like
happens here and look for new
opportunities unfortunately I didn't
find a single opportunity instead I
found a whole bunch of students and got
more involved in the Entrepreneurship
and innovation development rather than a
single venture or a single business so
that's been going on since around 1999
and in that time I've seen a progression
maybe of entrepreneurship worldwide but
certainly progression of how
entrepreneurship is viewed in in
Southeast Asia especially at a policy
that's kind of where I'm at focus today
I think some of it is generalizable to
the world in general outside of Silicon
Valley or outside of Boston or outside
just a couple of other areas other parts
are generalizable generalizable to the
developing world and some of its
probably focused mostly on Thailand
Southeast Asia you have to figure out
the differences between those but that's
kind of what we're going to be looking
at so it seems like we moved into this
world where entrepreneurship is being
sold as the easiest thing in the world
anyone can do it just add water you know
and that's that's kind of where we are
and and that affects unfortunate
unfortunately i'm going to say affects a
lot of important policy decisions in a
lot of countries around the world so
what I want to talk about is some magic
words that are bantered about all the
time you know we talk about innovation
ecosystems but I want to make a
distinction between ecosystems for
innovators and the question of whether
those ecosystems are actually innovative
or not okay so this is the distinction
that we're going to look at here because
as my friend ed here who's seen a lot of
my talk said you know don't do what
we're doing here well unfortunately
that's exactly what we're trying to do
and one of the messages here is I think
it's it's hurting us and wasting a lot
of resources so let's talk this is a
little bit of review if you've seen this
before this is a little bit of a review
of the kind of foundation of how I look
at an ecosystem so let's look at Silicon
Valley versus developing countries or or
a lot of other places in the world okay
so and my students have heard this a
million times so you have to bear with
it again so my view of people in the
world you can cut people up in a whole
different ways you can cut them up as
males or females or different
nationalities or different cultures or
whatever but with the work I do and the
things I'm interested in I kind of cut
people up this way okay there are people
who like to do new things and try things
new and take risks and and and do it
almost for the fun of it whether it
works or not and then then there's kind
of this mass market which is
doing what mass-market people do they do
things to get the the you know the
silver car then they get things do
things to get to the gold card and then
they do things to get to the platinum
card and so on and so forth and that's
kind of how mass markets are developed
and then there's a whole bunch of people
over here probably will never get it and
we don't really talk about them okay but
I'm always interested in this group here
and to the extent people want how to
move people here further that way okay
how do you know I'm not saying you have
to jump over to here and all of us are
here somewhere right we don't all
innovate with every decision we make you
know sometimes we just walk in and buy
something but I'm always hoping just
from a lifestyle choice to get people to
think a little bit more innovative about
some aspect of their life okay so that's
kind of how I view people in the world
and then if you view people in the world
and you start putting in a business
context you imagine how markets develop
okay again this is pretty standard
straight out of a marketing textbook
theory you know you feel these
innovators down here start doing
something and they they sell it as a
service and you're at the beginning of a
new market and if it continues to move
that way adding more people this market
begins to grow all right the the
so-called s-curve okay and if you put my
terminology on it this is by no means a
technical term but if my terminology
kind of fits something like this you
know when you're down and hear the
people are kind of saying you know I
don't really know where we're going but
it feels like we're onto something and
if more and more people kind of come
into the market and you'll earn your
business models a little bit better you
know you you you're in a growth stage
where a path is beginning to emerge and
then while you're up when you're up here
you know you're in that world where
everything is cut and dried you know
exactly what steps it takes to be a
beginner and intermediate and advanced
you know one star 5 stars10 stars
whatever the measurement is of the
market that you're in and if you think
about it most developed markets are
built around weird measurements you know
where we're getting awards for kind of
moving up this path you know and so it's
kind of how market develops right
so let's imagine what we were doing if
we're looking at the market of
innovation or the market of
entrepreneurship now this step is a
little bit confusing so I want to make
sure we're clear before we go forward
I'm making a distinction between what we
are able to do the products we use the
services we use that kind of stuff
versus the environment we are in okay
and the reason I'm making that
distinction is we can talk about
innovative products we can also talk
about the environment we're in and today
I'm focusing on the second one I'm
making this distinction because most of
us are used to Oh Jerry we're just
talking about you okay most of us are
used to thinking about innovation in
this first context you know products
start out very innovative and there but
they're kind of rough and people don't
know how to use them only a small number
of people try them and then they get
more polished and they they get
financing behind them and they get
distributions and they get easier to use
that's that's what most of us view on
innovation but I'm talking about
something else I'm talking about how an
environment for innovation develops and
evolve so taking that distinction and by
the way feel free to ask a question if
this is confusing but you know jump jump
right in we'll have a conversation about
this but if we're taking this further
you know we could say the same thing
about being an entrepreneur being an
entrepreneur in an innovative
environment or non innovative
environment so you know I'm not talking
about the product now I'm talking about
the act of being entrepreneurial you
know there are places in the world
Thailand is one of them where you need
to kind of find your own path all right
if you if you want to kind of go out and
do something or start something new or
whatever you kind of need to find your
own path and we might be somewhere like
around here a few years ago we're down
here and the distinction making is by
the time you get up here this is this is
where silicon valley is right it's not
that innovative products and services
aren't being developed here but the act
of being an entrepreneur
is very straightforward right you know
exactly you know looking techcrunch look
at you no meet-ups find the first place
that you want to do make connections you
know exactly who to talk to for Angel
funny you know exactly it's angel and
then a round and this that and the other
thing and everything is laid out step by
step so the act of being entrepreneurial
is very codified alright so that's the
distinction I'm discussing about here so
with that in mind we can draw a contrast
that Silicon Valley is probably
responsible for creating very innovative
products but I argue that the pathway of
entrepreneurship is not innovative it's
a well-trod path that all of you who are
based around here kind of know where to
follow now it wasn't 30 years ago it
wasn't very true but now it's a very
clear path and then you contrast that to
where we are oops perhaps probably the
products being developed are less
innovative but the challenge of being an
entrepreneur requires you to be a lot
more innovative you know who you go to
get mentorship where you go to get
funding where you go to get support
where you go to cry on people's
shoulders you know that's not very well
defined so that's the distinction that
is underlying our discussion today is
how we develop that ecosystem okay and
that's why I kind of argue that at least
for the spewing from the outside you
know Silicon Valley is is that
supermarkets got everything you know
exactly where to go you know everything
is lined out nicely and and and well
organized and then there's those of us
out in the rest of the world in these in
these chaotic markets trying to figure
out how do we get ourselves from these
these messy markets into something nice
and organized and exciting like Silicon
Valley so that's what we're discussing
so Silicon Valley entrepreneurs don't
necessarily need to be that innovative
as they go through the entrepreneurial
process although they may be making very
innovative products in developing
countries and else
where as i'm going to point out with an
example you know entrepreneurs really
need to find their own path still you
know they need to figure out where
they're going on their own they have to
be innovators within that process
although their opportunities may come
from more commonplace actions basic
products that you take for granted basic
services you take for granted getting
distribution out there to places that
you would take for granted in a place
like Silicon Valley or the west coast so
this is the problem all right imagine
this supermarket okay everyone else in
the world is saying god we need a
supermarket just like that when we need
to have that thing where we are and
that's what I want to discuss today and
see how well that's working so for the
people who around me what is copying a
Silicon Valley ecosystem mean what does
it look like well you know it's make
more Google's its venture capital driven
investment it's spaces creative spaces
okay and it is really this feeling that
entrepreneurship is a very clearly
defined step-by-step process that's the
way it's viewed by policymakers in most
of the rest of the world I'll speak
pretty well-informed of Thailand
Southeast Asia but i'm pretty sure from
my experiences with colleagues around
the world this is kind of the belief
outside outside of here now what does
that mean so you know what happens when
you're trying to either bring this
supermarket to an undeveloped market or
you're an underdeveloped market and you
want a supermarket right it's kind of
the same question depending on where you
stand now I'm going to talk about one
undeveloped market all right and the
reason I'm using this example is I'm
specifically not talking about
developing countries here I want to make
is clear that undeveloped markets exist
everywhere when we're talking about
innovation is you're going to see in a
second this is a story about Apple
and Nokia now I know you've heard about
Apple have you heard of Nokia I mean
it's a newer generation maybe nokia
didn't exist when you guys are alive
right you've heard of nokia nokia with
the big phone before Apple came along
right what year was the iphone released
well the Apple iPhone Apple became a
phone company in 2007 now that's a very
magical year for nokia why is that such
a magical year for nokia any nokia
experts in here let's be some telecom
people in here old all over some
something what was so important 2007 was
a very important year for nokia which
actually had nothing to do with apple
what or everything to do with Apple
maybe as you look at 2007 was the
highest sales year ever for nokia okay
the highest sales year ever this is
important part of the story so you know
nokia was down here in 1999 they grew
and grew and grew and grew and grew up
to here and that they hit the highest
point in their growth in 2007 and then
yes Apple came along so they started to
decline and they held out for a little
bit and then they dropped a little
plateau but really we know the rest of
the story okay so what happened with
let's use all the typical hypotheses
they got big and stupid you know they
didn't know what was going on they
didn't listen to the customers what
happened to nokia anybody know one
opinion there's a shareholder okay they
still general yeah yeah they're coming
back actually on the enterprise I
couldn't tell you how many shares its
insignificant didn't good nokia made the
decision when when they were faced with
the competition of the first smartphone
from apple to try to put out the next
generation smartphone as opposed to
putting out something that was equally
good okay they failed and so they lost
out on the existing market the
replacement or the comparable market and
had nothing for the future great by the
way I don't know you don't mean to give
you my opinion as well so any other I
hold on just a second Oh ed would you
really give a brief summary of that
because I'm not sure how much the
microphones in the room picked up what
Oh what EDD said sorry what that said
yeah so ed said he's a shareholder and
he's not banking on any money from Nokia
for his retirement and basically he said
nokia tried to leap to a
second-generation smartphone when Apple
came out with their first smartphone and
that missed the entire replacement
market that Apple was kind of creating
any other thoughts that's a good one
that's maybe better than mine i'll use
that next time ok any other theories
what happened to nokia i saw another
hand here's a similar okay i by jose
story okay so for me the key point in
this is this this change from stupid
phone to smartphone of course they
weren't stupid phones then they were
great phones then but then it was a
smarter phone that came along all right
but there was a significant difference
between a nokia phone and what became
called a smartphone from a technology
point of view what was a significant
difference sorry okay yeah that's a
product but i mean from a technology
point of view what was the difference
between a nokia phone and an apple phone
what became touchscreen okay what does
that mean smartphone okay okay the big
difference is it went from a hardware
device to a software device right so
what nokia did really really well was a
technology which was completely unusable
in that new type of product their bread
and butter product was this thing with
52 keys on it little teeny keys okay
right it was a hardware phone they knew
how to make little keyboards they lived
in a mechanical world ok our
electromechanical world the smartphone
or what we call a smartphone became a
software driven device right like all
Apple products they remove buttons and
they don't really remove buttons they
just make him in a software by
right that's what they're really doing
so I had a chance to talk with esco a ho
who is one former prime minister of
Finland the youngest prime minister
Finley's 36 years old when became prime
minister but after that he became the
vice president and joy Nokia's executive
board in 2008 and when I was asked to go
this talk I thought this guy's just
going to be making excuses but he didn't
make any excuses all he came right out
and hid in up so 2008 he's he's right
there at the the peak going down and he
presided over the failure of Nokia and
he was so honest about it it was
incredible so what changed you know he
said this he said you know phones moved
from being hardware oriented to software
on it we were experts nokia was experts
at making hardware driven phones
keyboards and that kind of stuff more
importantly they knew it was happening
they had played with touchscreens they
there was no it wasn't a they weren't
blindsided in the sense that they didn't
know what's happening they weren't blind
side in the sense they didn't know the
technology existed they were blindsided
by something completely different they
didn't have the ecosystem and and he
said this when I was talking he said we
did not have enough software engineers
in Finland we didn't have enough
software engineers in all of Europe to
compete with a software company in
Silicon Valley right it was a complete
change in the way things were created
and deployed it include the App Store it
included touchscreen but those were in a
blurs to a software world a very
flexible world okay whereas the old
phones were really built around keyboard
and electromechanical devices and his
point was we had only one choice we
could have moved to Silicon Valley and
we discussed that again and they weren't
oblivious to what was going on they
discussed the possibility and they said
my god that's such a risk we don't know
where this is heading you know it
signals an entire failure of everything
that we've done
and we're having our best sales ever how
do we tell anybody how do we tell our
shareholders about this move right and
so you can when you begin to hear this
you almost see the logic involved in
fact I say to myself what I made a
different decision if I were in the room
now the young people say of course not
because you're an old person but I would
argue the same thing with with any of us
in the room could we have could we in
the face of that evidence you know best
sales ever and we have no none of these
resources anywhere near as for thousands
of miles could we make a strategic
decision like that this is the
interesting thing well give you an
example somebody who's trying so Ford I
picked this off a verge just a couple
weeks ago I think this is only a couple
he was just here right now tell you a
side story mark fields is the CEO of
Ford mark fields used to be the CEO of
Mazda one of the things that got him to
where he is today is he visited my
business in Thailand I don't think he
shares it with many people so I'm
telling you myself okay I've met mark
fields but but what was interesting this
in 2001 in 2001 when he visited even
then the four people were saying he's
going to be CEO someday I mean so he is
set up a an app's company basically a
mobility company in Silicon Valley
really trying to head off some of what I
think Nokia was was a victim of so
interesting we'll see how it turns out
okay so what can we do those of us not
here well we can move here Ford's trying
to nokia didn't I'm not really willing
to once a year's good twice here's good
but there's some other things about
Thailand which are fun okay we can copy
Silicon Valley or we can try something
new so what's the best thing we can do
we copy Silicon Valley of course right
and this is what policymakers do around
the world all right let's let's look at
how this turns out so
we're trying to copy this remember one
the one the biggest ingredients in our
view of Silicon Valley and we had some
discussion and I think we could even
have some philosophical discussions if
this is the main driver venture capital
but one of the views of those of us not
Silicon Valley is venture capital drives
every decision you make all right but
the weird thing is in the u.s. u.s. vc
funding is essentially flat now Richard
pointed out to me if you get a little
bit I used a smoothing function on my
graph same data but smooth the doll a
bit more but it should come up well
actually I was also looking at the
amount of money not the number of deals
yes and that of course gets involved
with how valuations track the general
state of the economy so that's actually
a probably a better indicator than I was
using earlier yeah in fact i'm NT i use
number of deals here the next slide
actually unfortunately use value i meant
to use number of deals because i think
that's more appropriate from region to
region because the values are so of it
no so in matt night I mean look at this
1995 all the way through 2015 the only
time it really changed appreciably this
is this is the number of venture capital
deals in the whole us i'm not talking
about Silicon Valley it moves around
regionally you know cilic malli draws
from other places and sometimes others
flare up but if you take all of the US
except for the 2001 debacle when people
learned all right vc has been flat so
even though we're maybe driving more
customers to our through our through our
ecosystem supermarket our
entrepreneurship supermarket there's the
same number of deals being done for 20
years now okay so and we're copying that
that's kind of weird all right it's like
copying a business model where you're
trying to grow the customers but the
supply is is fixed there's another part
of the deal the explanation about
venture cap which i think is even more
important for those of us not living
here so this is funding bye-bye key
areas it's it's basically in dollars and
it's maybe too small to read down here
but
this one is software then you get to
biotechnology get to consumer products
and services media entertainment IT
services and then you get down to a
whole bunch of other things industrial
energy financial services medical
devices so on and so forth venture
capital is extremely focused in what it
works in and this is true worldwide and
yet those of us who live in other parts
of the world are constantly thinking
about venture cap we need venture
capital but even here in the mecca of
venture capital venture capital is
extremely focused in only a couple of
areas in fact even though there's a lot
of categories there I would argue in the
least those first five are all software
right software software you'll give me
that one for sure biotechnology today is
is a software game it's an information
game you know biotech companies rely
heavily on information also goes back to
gene sequencing but the the techniques
are very much software techniques and
then you when you get into consumer
products and services media
entertainment IT services I mean I'm
assuming I'm going to make the
assumption here that those are heavily
driven in software so what it means is a
huge chunk of the VC world is chasing IT
and software now there's a problem with
software for those of us who live
everywhere else to problems actually
it's incredibly flexible and it's full
of bugs now why is this a problem for
Thailand well first of all any country
specific advantage we might get like
language is extremely easy to drop into
the next version right you can add
languages to any software package
extremely easy and any one who has more
the more customers you have the more bug
fixers you have right so it's going to
be very very hard for a language
specific or region specific software
industry to take off now I know there's
some exceptions I'll try to deal with
them in my way and in a few slides but
in general if this is the software part
of the you know center of the world it's
going to be really really hard to set up
something new because software requires
requires a scale and benefits from the
scale all right so how do you edge your
self in you know the only advantage is
that we we can the only two I can come
up with language and accounting
practices right those are the two things
that might make software different but
those are really easy to build into
other versions of software hard to
maintain that advantage okay so here's
what we're looking at you know we're
looking at this vision or our
policymakers people who work who I work
with and and unfortunately give me a lot
of money to do run programs and stuff
are trying to create something like
Silicon Valley but it's based on a
couple of things that may not be true
here and the things that aren't true
here are not applicable at all to our
part of the world okay so so here are
some views i have in in errors of copy
in Silicon Valley first of all in
general thailand's technical strengths
aren't IT there are some great coders
and great programmers and there are some
great programs from other parts of the
world who have chosen to live in
Thailand and code for wherever their
customers are a worldwide but still you
don't really get the benefits of any
thai language advantage because the real
advantage is here okay there are some
places who believe that they have hope
right first of all china's a closed IT
market the biggest advantage chinese
software companies have is no one else
can get in there okay india also has
some hope and they have the benefit of
have have had a strong IT services
industry for many decades now which has
moved up the value chain they also have
the benefit of numbers huge numbers of
people come and study here and then go
back and take their capabilities so
india has a strong possibility of
building
Israel is always cited as one of the
up-and-coming places they're backed by
some great strengths and defense you
know security and defense driven
applications but it's still small coming
8 million people right so Israel is is
is is batting above its weight punching
above its weight for sure but it's it's
still a small country so it's really
hard to imagine if we're going back to
this and saying we need to build
something like this somewhere else in
the world really really hard to imagine
how that's going to happen okay hard for
me to imagine I can introduce you to a
lot of people who imagine it all the
time okay so the other thing we can we
can get on then is well what about stuff
that Thailand is good at and Thailand is
good at a lot of things okay two of them
very very good agriculture we got some
great cutting edge world-class
agriculture technology anybody heard of
a VC firm investing in agriculture it
does happen but if you dig deeply it's
almost always an IT related connection
back back to agriculture so even in the
US with all the agriculture research
research going on here all the venture
capital activity going on here nobody
has found a venture capital model for
for agriculture and of course things
like tourism right great industry very
innovative industry hospitality but it's
that also isn't built around a
innovation or doesn't really allow a
Silicon Valley type innovation ecosystem
now are these really right for venture
based ecosystems that's kind of the
problem I have when I look at this
challenge so what can we do I cross the
first one off early all right hopefully
we're we're beginning to agree that's
going to be hard to copy so now we're
we're left to the undesirable one we got
to do something new
we need to try something new so let's
choose an ecosystem to Bill okay we
talked about i.t already let's cross
that one off we talked tourism hard to
imagine agriculture hard imagine but
what about an ecosystem built on
problems okay this is this is that the
next step some of you have heard my
earlier presentations this is the
evolution of that thinking what if we
built an ecosystem built on the problem
rather than the technology here's how
the thinking goes first of all let me
give you some history a little bit
history of actually how Silicon Valley
came along but John just a little bit I
got criticized by somebody last time I
gave some history they said don't come
in here and tell us about Silicon Valley
history okay but originally you know if
you if you kind of look at some of the
stuff you know the modern venture
capital kind of came out of the Boston
area there was this guy at Harvard who
you know said hey we got some business
sense and those guys down at heart at
MIT have got a whole bunch of
technologies the war is ended what do we
do with them all right so the the
original seeds of modern venture capital
came from trying to find consumer
applications or let's say other
applications industrial applications for
war technologies so this is the 50s
radio is one of those in fact radio
figure prominently in in the formation
the Silicon Valley ecosystem okay but
again it was radio right we have this
technology we can we can broadcast radio
waves we can transmit information radio
waves now what do we do with it well
that became successful knows were the
first stages where Fred Terman began to
really build what would become called
Silicon Valley although if he had been
real successful radio would have been
vacuumed to Valley I guess but so he
didn't get radio to really catch on but
it really began to cement his thinking
and that moved on to the next step we're
really became silicon-based okay now
we've got transistors another kind of
war post-war technology but it was
so a technology seeking a problem in
those days they didn't know what to do
transits with transistors they knew it
was going to revolutionaries everything
but but how and so that moved on in fact
there's a step in between here I could
probably put in here it's when these
transistors started going on chips which
kind of comes into some of our vintage
right and you know what do we do with
these semiconductors and that's what it
was when I was a kid as a high school
and when I was in high school you know
semiconductor manufacturers would make
little what they called computers my
first computer was something called a
Kim one there might be three people in
the room who know what that was a Kim
one the whole purpose that was just to
get people using the 6502 chip on there
at 1k of memory no storage all
hexadecimal input machine language okay
again there are hobbyists we didn't know
what to do with it we just we saw this
week we imagined this future but we just
didn't know what that future was going
to hold okay pc same way when pcs first
came out i remember in high school
people like apple running ads look at
all the stuff you can do on a pc
actually wouldn't said that sorry on a
microcomputer look at all the things you
can do on a microcomputer keep recipes
keep address books keep you know they're
trying to tell us what we might use a
computer for a microcomputer in those
days again it's a problem I mean it's a
kind of a solution or technology still
trying to find that that problem begin
to happen with the internet and in fact
internet was actually a war technology
if you go far enough back same way you
know we have this internet we built this
internet so that we could bomb ourselves
to oblivion and the internet would still
survive okay but there wasn't any
consumer applications with it after a
while a couple scientists not even
computer scientists physicists started
sending email back and forth and
collecting things together and what
would be the world wide web but it was
still lacking in it in a a product or a
need so our entire world of innovation
ecosystems up until now up until now our
solutions seeking problems I trying to
turn that around what about
eco systems based on problems searching
for solutions we live in a part of the
world that has lots of problems you live
in a world that has no problems right
but lots of solutions okay so why would
we chase after a method which doesn't
fit so here's what I'm proposing as the
next possible step wicked problems worth
working on now wicked problem is
actually a technical term as some of my
students know that they love this word
okay wicked problem is actually a word
that was a term that was coined by a
development expert from UC berkeley's
it's not meant to be a you know a
millennial term or a marketing term and
actually has a technical connotation
it's a it's a very very complex complex
problem so I'm trying to imagine how to
define these wicked problems worth
working on which then become ecosystems
so how do we set a methodology to find
these wicked problems now the reason I
I'm keen on this methodology is for a
couple reasons is I believe for the
ecosystem to work it needs to somehow
attract both investors and entrepreneurs
right just like it did 50 or 60 years
ago in in those early days coming out of
the war a small number a very small
number of investors with a new idea of
how investing could be saw let's take
these technologies and build an
ecosystem around it I'm suggesting the
same thing we find that we're able to
identify a small number of investors and
they're out there as I'll show you small
new investors hey we should be investing
in problems rather than investing in
solutions and encouraging their for
encouraging entrepreneurs and all of
them coming around to a certain point to
a single point where the ecosystem grows
and that's the challenge is how to get a
well-defined wicked problem okay I've
chosen a number this is fairly arbitrary
there's a little bit of hopefully
educated guess into it but fairly
arbitrary 10 to 50 million people the
goal is to be focused enough to attract
those investors and entrepreneurs
because there are investors interested
in specific areas and hopefully if it's
focused enough an entrepreneur can
imagine working in a certain area so I'm
arbitrarily saying 10 to 50 million
people for that desire for scale I'm
suggesting our methodology includes
looking for problems that go across the
country barrier right it's that's more
interesting from an international point
of view and the overall goal of this is
we are able to define a well-defined
problem which is used to line
entrepreneurs and investors and other
resources into an innovation ecosystem
because when you think about it that's
all that happens in this supermarket
called Silicon Valley is everything all
these resources financial human and
technical resources get aligned more or
less in one single area that's what
makes it work and that's what I'm hoping
we're able to do from a another point of
view and that is from the problem rather
than solution now where am I looking for
inspiration for this methodology by the
way the methodology is important because
I think if you're able to show a
methodology or describe a methodology it
adds credibility to those people who are
trying to bring in both on the investor
side and the entrepreneur side so we the
terminology we use in our program is
explore experiment execute but
essentially it's design it's it's it's a
design thinking sort of philosophy now
design thinkers or designers you know
the ideas and the Frog designs and
Continuum's and those guys believe that
they've got a process for creating good
designs and if you go back in history 15
or 20 years they focus that process on
products and then over time they said
hey this doesn't only have to be four
products it can also be four services
and then going more closely to the
present they started saying hey doesn't
to be for services it can be for the
entire brand or strategy of our company
that's kind of where we are here so all
I'm suggesting really is can we use that
same process for 50 million people 10 to
50 million people okay so product is
kind of one scale of that design
thinking services skein a little bit
further strategy and brand scale a
little bit further can we take it to a
regional level can we still apply a
design kinky methodology to a regional
level to get a well thought-out problem
not solution so sometimes we use this
terminology 10 10 10 right easy to
remember okay so we're trying to imagine
10 wicked problems were working on which
offend 10 million people 50 just doesn't
fit in here but okay to be solved over
10 years again ecosystem venture capital
like timelines right not that quick
fixes but good long-term problems that
that really are going to attract people
into those area area so and I believe if
we get this methodology down well we'll
be able to galvanize entrepreneurs
investors to come together and and maybe
change the way we look at ecosystems all
right so my assumption is that the the
method is part of the whole intrigue
that people get turned on by by this
method not just some arbitrary
definition of water or poverty or rural
but by having a good methodology that
tracks these kind of people who say hey
that's what I want to be part of so
that's our next step I hear this all the
time you hear this statement all the
time you know I talk to investors
investors I get an investor call me
every week saying hey you know I've got
money I want invest in you know I looked
up some number impact investors
supposedly seven hundred million dollars
they're trying to deploy to solve
problems around the little around the
world so there's a lot of money out
there I get calls emails all the time
and if I suggest anything the answer is
always well there's not a market for
that I mean how can it not be a market
if there's a problem that big
alright so that's why I'm trying to
imagine this step from problem problem
to market and if we get that then we've
taken the next step to building the
ecosystem so that's what I consider my
next step in the development working on
if you have them back next year I'll
tell you how to do it I'm better get it
out yet okay but really that's what
we're trying to do is is have
problem-based ecosystems that achieve
the same things happening in Silicon
Valley but use one resource that we have
a lot of math problems thank you Thanks
so so let me ask the first question so
this idea of building maybe not an
ecosystem and certainly building a
startup company around a problem is not
unknown here either a lot of people
would say that so I uber came about
right yep no taxis in San Francisco so
what's it going to look like do you
think that the system especially in
Southeast Asia's kind of look more at
infrastructure or do you think it's
going to look at consumer demand what's
going to be the driving things okay so
this is a great question that I don't
know the answer to okay because i think
i've been experimenting with this for
about three years I've got some guinea
pigs in the room and many others okay
we've experiment with with mba students
we've experiment with researchers and
we're always trying to define and figure
out how to define this wicked problem
and one thing that happened there's this
two things that happen which which I
don't believe is what I'm heading for
either somebody jumps to a solution
immediately which I'm trying to stop or
it's defined at a scale which is ideal
as a startup company like an like an
oeuvre No so what I'm suggesting is and
I'm admitting I don't know the way what
I'm suggesting is if there's a way to
think one scale above that so the
problem with an uber not uber as it
exists but and and uber like in
something in the developing world is
there isn't an ecosystem around it so
all the benefit you have an ecosystem
here we're talking about it's just
before class right there's 15 people all
making a similar company in any one
thing you know Airbnb or uber or
whatever
it is there's lots of people sharing
ideas all in the same area there's lots
of investors with money out there
playing in a similar area so if it's a
if it's a single problem on a single
company not here that company has very
little chance of moving forward so how
do we scale up one magnitude so it's no
longer a company-sized it's it's region
sized so that now a handful of investors
are there a handful of entrepreneurs or
more are there and now there's some
healthy competition there's some healthy
sharing of ideas that ecosystem so in my
mind it's really a difference of scale
and I don't know I agree it kept so far
in my efforts is always collapsed either
to a solution or its collapse to a
problem to a scale a company's scale
problem but if we could keep it at a
higher scale I think we could allow
multiple entrepreneurs and multiple
investors to come together yeah I'm
actually familiar with one example in
the province of quebec canada where the
province got together and they held a
conference on problems they said those
conferences of innovation are about
solutions that they took exactly this
line and they basically had people come
out who made presentations about the
problems and i don't know what follow-up
they did right I don't know if the
entrepreneurs and the investors sitting
in the room actually were able to talk
to each other and coordinate things but
of course you know in their situation
one of the problems was manufacturing
facilities that no longer had any use
right I remember that being a big thing
I wanted to kind of drill down on this
just a little bit more and the yeah the
the issue is kind of do it who do you
think it is is this something that the
government could bring the right people
in the room and who are the right people
in the room ah no my belief is no on
that because hope is still on who does
not live phone ok the you know that we
talked about this a little bit earlier
the government people I know and and
they're big supporters of what I do I
should scramble the next part because i
know this is on video you know they mean
well and they want to do good things but
they're not going to take a risk so it's
a lot easier to say hey let's do what
Silicon Valley is doing and that's why
we see this proliferation everywhere
you're never going to say hey it's
stupid it with Silicon Valley's doing
you know you know so government doesn't
do that as well but if but there are
there are investors out there with a lot
of money there are entrepreneurs al'Thor
who want to solve lots of problems and
by the way this comes from my experience
I've worked for about 10 or 15 areas in
this 10 or 15 years in this area that
sometimes called social entrepreneurship
and you get lots of different business
models and they never they never come
together in kind of an area so that's
what I'm hoping to do is take that next
step instead of one guy working on rural
area and one guy working on crime in the
city you know let's get people to to
really come around a problem in a big
way it's kind of like what Bill Gates
was trying to do with the global health
challenges although in my opinion most
of global health challenges are more
solution-based rather than problem-based
yeah one last comment for me and then
we'll open open the floor one kind of
interesting thing about this is that in
the product driven innovation if you
would the solution driven innovation one
of the things that you see is you see
people who have a thing right and they
are unable to have the flexibility to
see other applications for it and I
think there is a danger in this solution
that people think they know what a
problem is and they don't have the
flexibility to redefine the problem and
look at it in a new and different way
yeah that's the key of that methodology
defining a problem is actually one of
the hardest things you can do I've been
researching this for about five years
I've not found a good way to define a
problem it's harder than it sounds the
design thinking approach though is a
really good idea because you look at it
from different angles you tried small
solutions early yep and really get them
out into the market
yeah ok let's open the floor bebin hi I
give you a problem there you define your
problem as a wicked problem yeah and use
the wicked problem is that when you
define it changes now if the problem
keeps changing government will have done
be able to support it yeah venture
capital is built on that either so maybe
you should change the definition of the
problem your work yeah I actually bring
a very interesting point because you're
right one of the deaf one of the
technical definitions of wicked problems
are they actually change as you're
trying to solve them or or your
understanding changes that you're trying
to solve them and they're moving all the
time so let me just tell you a little
bit of how we got to wicked problem I
used to call them grand challenges and I
had two problems with Grand Challenges
number one most the grand challenges
I've seen different find which includes
the gates grand challenges for global
health the Canada grand challenges even
the Academy of Engineering grand
challenges they're all solution based
technology based okay you know Gates's
list is an incredible list but it's you
know make refrigerated it make vaccines
that don't even be refrigerated great i
can see the value of that but that's
different than what i was trying to do
so that was one problem with grand
challenges but i was still okay with it
then but then i gave a presentation like
this a few years ago to a whole bunch of
senior scientists and won the senior
scientists started calling his work
grand challenges and so grand challenges
in thailand became what he wanted to
work on what the other scientists so
unfortunately i can't use grand
challenges so I I kind of got into
wicked problems but you're right we
could problems it's a cool name but it
doesn't exactly fall a definition so
actually I saw your hand first yeah you
mentioned that the government in
Thailand in other developing countries
try two copies in the klang valley yeah
they actually this worldwide everyone
could could you please elaborate more on
what exactly they are trying to do sure
um usually build build a big building
okay you put in a space a creative space
you know which has gains in it beanbag
stuff like that you put a whole bunch
little offices in which will be startup
offices
you encourage venture capital to come in
and then you have lots and lots of
events usually inviting people in
Silicon Valley come over and speak this
would be for example maybe Singapore
Malaysia every country in the world
actually every region the world besides
Boston and and San Francisco and maybe
Seattle in austin and cambridge maybe
tel aviv everywhere else we've already
got the booze oh yeah but everywhere
else even even regions in the u.s. try
to do this okay it's more they feels
more the physical space rather than the
glue and the networking I to separate
points to make one is I find your
approach very inviting and I think it is
wonderful you know it's not just blindly
copying some of them dead and so on as
an aside i will talk about Silicon
Valley is that in terms of the ecosystem
well what has happened and this is just
something that everybody knows so it's
nothing to be discussed because more
important thing is this one is that of
course when you have an ecosystem like
this and proliferation of companies what
has been what I'm seeing crease in the
newspapers for the last couple of years
is of course the driving out of the
lower wage workers or and and of course
the lower wage workers now include
teachers professors you know insurance
agents and all that everybody's low-wage
who isn't a Silicon Valley millionaire
and of course you do see homeless
families and children no in fact there's
this bus for hotel 22 which is an in
overnight bus so that's another problem
and again that so copying blindly
Silicon Valley will lead to other
problems in other countries with more
disastrous results my boy I agree I
agree and that's happening in places
like India where brand new cities come
in and everyone else has pushed out the
brand new city is built around an
information I t-hub or something like
that so I really ain't but my more
important thing is I was actually just
at the connecting the dots imposing I'd
be
need this with you thank you one of the
things that dr. Marcia McNutt she spoke
about she didn't she have science
magazine and you know with her totally
go Sumerians and everything else she
talked about she mentioned of course the
whole focus is on energy climate change
and so on and one of the things she
mentioned was that she felt that in the
developing countries again the copying
mentality and I think it isn't
necessarily development countries I
think it has always been very much the
premise of this is short yet because I
have to tell you this is all going to go
on YouTube they tend not to pay
attention to what's happening in the
audience and so really I'm going to have
to ask ed to do a real brief summary so
that some of this content can come back
alternative source of energy in
developing countries great I mean I
agree that's why my view of the world is
this it's not developing versus
developed and that's why i put the nokia
example in there i mean feeling nobody
would in accused finland of being a
developing country but when the
technology changed its it doesn't have
what it needs to do that so this is the
way I view the world there's there's
some people here and there's a whole
bunch of people who love to follow
what's going on okay good go ahead I
feel like people invest in investors
invest in people and people like
founders have they treat their venture
as like their baby but if you flip fit
and you find people to work on your
problems when the going gets tough why
won't they just stopped because they
don't have that drive that the founders
here do no there's no change the founder
is still going to be working on their
venture their venture is still going to
be solving a problem just like adventure
here at solving a problem actually we
had an interesting discussion thats
related to this at lunch because a lot
of info on trapani really start their
dreams because they want to change the
world they see a match if it's solution
driven they see a match between
something they've got an a real world
problem and in the process of growing a
company the company almost has to
gradually transition away from the
entrepreneurs ownership and to the
ownership of investors who
primary interest is financial return and
this is something structural that
happens because a lot of entrepreneurs
stop too quickly if they are not really
pushed by investors to keep growing
their companies yeah I think that's a
very good you know very I don't think we
got any question actually so a lot of
people a lot of founders have like
personal interest and that's why they
stick through it to get to that phase
but I feel like if it's this way imagine
it's like you have a kid or you it is
really bad example but if you're asked
to take care of your friends child at
like your house and like something
happens you would go to your kit first
so you can worry about you know with
your idea what you're suggesting or and
I didn't mean imply this what you're
suggesting is is I man it's you come
help me with my problem that's not the
point there's people over the world who
are interested different challenges they
want to work in water they want to work
in rural poverty from that point of view
I don't think those problems are defined
focused enough in order for ecosystem
build around and so if you're interested
in water problems for example the idea
would be to define the problem more
narrowly so that so that first of all
affects about 10 to 50 million people
that attracts a whole bunch of people
who are working on their ventures but
are interested in that area and in trax
investors who are investing in what they
want invest in in that area just like
people come here because they want a
code they want to be an IT they want to
invest in IT so it's it's really not I'm
not telling you to come solve my problem
I'm just saying there are people out
there and if it's focused enough and the
money is there they're going to they
might go that way but in a sense you
can't own a problem like you can own the
solution right in terms of being you
know the person listed on the patent or
having the business or whatever I'm
skeptical about those but yeah well but
but you know the whole idea of ownership
how important is that to
entrepreneurship and one of the things
is that I think it was significant that
your comment comes from India because a
lot of this really looks like what has
happened with bottom of the pyramid
businesses especially you know that was
so famous and really has developed very
far in India and um are you seeing a lot
of entrepreneurs in Southeast Asia who
are really working on those kinds of
problems is this really actually
developing now or is this still
something that's a negative idea yeah
sure I mean so again nice and this goes
back to the question that this guy just
asked there are lots of people
interested in the bottom of the pyramid
but the bottom of the period is very
very broad and that that's one of my
concerns is resources are stretched very
very thin so if suddenly you said hey
we're going to we're going to put a lot
of effort in this one area I think it
would attract people just like some
people are attracted here because
there's opportunities in IT I don't
think they necessarily come here just
because their solution matches what's
here you know there's a give and take
and so same way the bottom of period is
very thin and very broad and if we were
able to define some much clearer
challenges wicked problems in those
areas 50 million people or so I think it
would hopefully coagulate some effort
rather than spreading it so thinly
that's the challenge most solutions I
see our village by village and they
never go beyond that that scale and that
that's an unfortunate use of resources
I'll let you call for all of us all your
hand this is sort of a quagmire too I
want to suggest that you were it could
be simpler than then you're making it
harder than it that is and an example of
what your asparagus is with country of
Chile has just recently done so chilly
is i think i would say that Chile's now
and like a second generation of evolving
their innovative ecosystem I think
they're they're not quite fast making
any consistent for innovators that
they're you know getting them mindset a
warning causing everybody across the
whole office popular say 16 million
people wanting to be innovative and is
proven by the by the sweetest atisha
that chili is about 1965 America
on you know that's them so they just
said what are we best at and what can we
what can we you know wrap innovation
around so that's a big copper and now
they come out with a whole roadmap for
ten years and how are we going to make
apply innovation and make you know
copper move forward and be the leading
edge so what would that thing be that
one area I mean maybe it's you know
whatever it is you're you're from
Thailand you should know what that one
really fabulous ecosystem is this I
think that's easier with 60 million than
it is with 80 million but but really
what I'm interested in is a challenge
beyond Thailand I'm interested in this
idea that you can define a series of
problems and attract people from around
the world so I'm actually not a policy
person and I'm really not interested in
in-country policy I'm really interested
to see how we could adjust the way
people innovated it took probably just
one step above what you're suggesting
but I agree that's one way is just to
kind of choose one for each country or
community or something like I agree with
that yeah so at the level of individual
entrepreneurs are you seeing people who
are not attuned well enough to market
needs or to the ecosystem around a
particular some people I see are
incredibly attune to market needs but
their market is a single village I mean
incredibly a tune they they are in that
village they are part of the fabric it
you cannot be more attuned to the needs
and I'm just wondering how do we pull
that out a little bit and enjoy it a
thousand times one of the reasons I ask
this is at the early in the first
session we looked at the rate of
percentage of the population who are
involved in entrepreneurial activities
and it's quite high in Thailand yeah so
in a sense you see a high percentage of
people in the population but the
efficiency and there's an there's
another message there's another measure
which isn't measured in many of those
studies and this it's kind of an
invention measurement and i don't mean
invention liking gadgets and that kind
of stuff I'm talking about people that
just solve their a problem in their
immediate area they they help their kids
at the school they fix this thing or
they fix that thing and that's that's an
inventor role and when I'm
imagine is how do you once somebody's
come up with that solution how do you
make it happen 500 times something like
that and and how do you reward investors
and entrepreneurs for being that that
scale that my students know that my view
of the world is these are inventors this
is the mass market and somewhere in here
the people who take this invention and
try to get it to larger numbers of
people so that's the view i have just
like a Bill Gates or a Steve Jobs said
and here's this this home computer how
do we put it on more desks around
America something like that I've seen
some great incredibly innovative ideas
in Southeast Asia and in India I just
never see them go any further and I'm
not saying they should but I'm saying
there's an opportunity if we can make
those go further maybe not for the
individual inventor but for somebody to
get it more widespread yeah we learned
in Richard seminar that there's one
place where China is actually out
innovating Silicon Valley and that's an
e-commerce um I've heard that if you
look at sophisticated ecommerce sites in
China it makes the Amazon look like it's
10 years old or outdated now if you look
at the demographics china i think has
110 cities with over a million people
the united states has even nine or ten
san jose would be the time okay so you
just don't have the distribution of mega
cities in effect were high density
ecommerce works where you can do one
hour shipping through our shipping 24
hours shipping that kind of thing right
so are there examples like that in
Southeast Asia we're playing to the
strength of what you South East Asia has
in that case it's China's population
density well what I'm arguing actually
is the opportunity is the problems right
there are a common set of problems there
are unique problems to every part of the
region but there are some common
problems that cut across the region
which I think we can bring together and
find investors and entrepreneurs to to
go after
for maybe a specific example one or two
I mean I mean if I was going to move
into a specific example anything having
to do with over overuse of aquatic or
agricultural resources is a big I mean
all the countries except for singapore
and brunei are very very agricultural so
that would be the first place to start
your search or or my searches is in
those areas then there's water
management there's a whole bunch of
things related to that those a hand up
here many times it is a simple question
what challenges to entrepreneurs face in
Thailand so that can be answered in a
number of different ways so the way I
would answer is they put a challenge on
themselves okay depends on what you want
expect from the entrepreneur but many
entrepreneurs in Thailand don't have the
same desire to build a company here like
somebody would build a company here you
said at lunch what was your profile of a
of an Asian entrepreneur or they become
comfortable once I start to generate
profit but there's a certain goal is
certain comfort it doesn't take long to
be comfortable as your to manage a small
company z to manage have you get a
certain amount of thirsty you can be on
as many panels as you want to speak on
you know the reward structure in fact i
was telling richard at lunch there's a
great opportunity i think so a medical
student in indonesia was sent out in a
village like they all are to work for
two years and this is a project we work
with and he found out that people in
came the clinic when they had money not
when they were sick they came when they
had money very very poor part of
Indonesia and so he set up a system
bring plastic bottles to me every month
bring this many plastic balls minimah
every month and whenever and then he
recycles them and whenever you're sick
you just come to a clinic he calls a
garbage clinical insurance brilliant
idea brilliant idea and he's evolved
he's worked on this for two years he's
got menus you know exactly how much to
bring how many plastic bottles how much
newspaper how much this mean he's
evolved in a very systematic way but he
loves his village he loves the local
Aires working on he's gotten worldwide
fame Prince Charles has been there and
had his pick
you're taken he gets flown somewhere
every month he takes one of his staff
with him every month he's got everything
he needs if not more from that project
and I would love to see him do a
thousand more times we've told them we
can bring investors in we can bring
operations people and he's happy with
what he's got and I can't say there's
anything wrong with that but that would
be one of the biggest things in teen in
terms of if you're talking about an
entrepreneur that you would see in this
area it wouldn't be cool to stop at low
scale here something we would call in
Silicon Valley a search fund which is
money looking for in off like a capable
entrepreneur or somebody who could fill
the fill those shoes and be like listen
here is a problem in fact in that case
you have a solution already set up we
just want you to do it in 20 other
villages just to scale this out man yeah
the company from 30 people to 300
different iceberg right so why doesn't
that exist but I think it's actually at
a more fundamental level it's the social
pressure it's a social reward so if
you're not if you're chatting someone
about a bar here if you're not talking
about you're gonna grow it in gazillion
times you're not cool you know when
you're in Thailand it's it or anywhere
else in Southeast Asia it's a different
set of social values and so and I think
most of us are motivated a lot by our
social environment and this social
environment motivates you in a different
way than the social environment so that
that's the thing that's going to be a
challenge there's not a lot of role
models to look to there's not a lot of
people who you're trying to outdo
there's not a lot of people who are
saying hey you're cool if you keep
making a bigger you're pretty cool doing
what you've done sexually this kind of
comes back to your question earlier what
happens if you lose interest in the
problem right those do they just walk
away because most people are very aware
of the problems right around themselves
and it's scaling beyond that to larger
groups is really hard go ahead
one reason yet it will work while in
ages because most of business is family
owned like I think we searched out with
opted to facility for steps he got from
raising such for ideas and actually in
an a or join of them a company and act
finally exit strategies no but the thing
the heart of things I can imagine in
asia's even though this company is
probable they won't really want to just
sell it to you because you really have
kind of passion or love into the
concrete decorated so that's one thing
it's not it's quite different compared
to the Western culture yeah social
values that are ruined and it's a cousin
another solid well my question is uh he
quickly introduced about what's the
current a start-up situation like and
Thailand or in general we say east
southeast asia yeah so again reason wise
is it's not not to two different than
anyone else so the lobby effort is in IT
and app comes accompanies the biggest
companies in the biggest startups in any
of the countries tend to be language
specific or some other idiosyncrasy with
that country which means their lip
they're capped already how far they can
go okay so you're you know companies in
Thailand or 10 million dollar companies
you know because that's that's what
they're going to reach and you know
companies in Malaysia same way companies
in even companies in Singapore you know
that Singapore is trying to promote
itself but it really hasn't had any big
breakthroughs either because the markets
if you're doing if you're trying to find
a market which is unique to Southeast
Asia nit it's a really small market and
it's a market that outside IT can move
in really quickly intake
there's in London feel like the prize
for Rose day no way I mean the ties are
manipulating the price in Thailand no no
okay so you're talking about whole new
industry I mean property is a big
industry it can be a very innovative
industries a highly competitive industry
but that's not I mean and it's a great
industry it's an interesting an industry
it doesn't really fit into this
discussion of you know venture capital
innovation ecosystem I mean if you go to
Thailand hotels are really really cool
and innovative shopping malls if you
like them are really cool and innovative
you know there are places where Thailand
is you know hospitals people fly around
the world to tie hospitals so I mean
there are places which are truly best in
the world they just don't fit in this
venture ecosystem but if you need
anything done in a hospital it's the
best place to go in fact it's great to
go to hospitals when you're not sick so
basically hotel do you think people in
Asia kind of back to the social values
thing do you think you'll be able to get
people in Asia speaking frankly enough
about the problems to really develop
focused problems you can work on because
there's an awful lot of unwillingness
you know don't hire a consultant because
we shouldn't admit that we need a
consultant right yeah that kind of
attitude I see part of it yeah it's true
and it's a good question because this
may be one of the barriers to getting
more focused definition of problems so
many of the problem lots of problems are
discussed but their disgust at what I
call newspaper headline level you know
which means they're just water poverty
corruption I mean that is such a broad
that's not a problem that's a issue and
those need to be broken in to clearly
define you know corruption could be
broken down into probably hundreds of
clearly defined problems that then could
be tackled and then then you want once
you get focused now somebody's in a
target but when their corruption in
general or water in general it doesn't
nobody's in the target crosshairs at
that point so how much have you talked
about this to people in the government
or in other groups that might move on
this I talk is about it's about everyone
so we've got a collection of time i
called my my question is what kind of
react
are you getting are you getting an
interest on the part of the people who
have the resources who would actually
start a program like this yeah actually
I'm not worried about the resources
because I've got enough in in impact
investors in the region and we've kind
of created a group which includes 16
these people whether they like it or not
but also people in other countries
through through our southeast asian
network people from UNICEF and and some
of the other eight organizations who are
developing entrepreneurs so we've got a
good group what I what I need to what
I'm telling myself with this
presentation is we really need to spend
an effort on the methodology and so I've
been trying to search whether a
methodology exists haven't really found
one I'm getting some help from frog
design numb the CEO of frog design he's
gone interested in this so it's really a
design thinking methodology and how to
apply that at a larger level okay so i
think on that note probably we should
call it into the formal part of today's
session we've got some refreshments
outside hope you'll stay and talk
informally with each other and also with
it first of all thanks so much for a
really thought-provoking presentation
thank you thank you thanks for having me
you